and you know um I um my father
is a prime example of the thing that I
was supposed to avoid essentially
um
I don't know my father since I was like
my father left me and my mom when I was
one year old
um and my mom always told me that he was
allowed to always like be part of my
life even if he wasn't part of her life
um and she was expecting him to do so
but he just wasn't when I was like I
don't know like uh four or five years
old I got like um a cheap toy motorcycle
um and then I that was it that was like
the one time I heard
from him until I was like 16.
um and then he met me just so that he
can give me my signature so I can change
my name
um and after that change it to his name
change it to my mom's family name right
that was on his name
um and and then he was like he beat he
beat himself in the chest with his fist
like oh I want to buy you a guitar or
something like that I want to spend more
time with you and I'm like
uh I don't believe that but you know I'm
gonna stay quiet see what you're gonna
do that never happened again uh again I
haven't heard from him since
I was like fair enough now funnily
enough I actually had um a message from
my mom saying your dad's been looking
for you and I'm like
look I'm 31 years old now uh I've
achieved more in my life
that than he achieved in his I I know I
know how he ended up I'm not curious to
be part of his life and I was like I'm
not interested I think I think that my
mom was a better role model a better
masculine role model for me than my dad
could ever been
are you saying
that your mother had to fulfill that
role she had to she had no choice right
because
um
otherwise in the ideal world you would
have preferred it to be him
no I would have preferred it to be
someone else that has a bit of cojones
yeah you know a bit more responsibility
look at me I'm 31 years old I don't have
a child because I've been responsible
I've been I've been engaged in sexual
activities
responsibly
um I've been protecting myself you know
like
I'm not married because I haven't found
the right person you know I'm not
jumping in you know willy-nilly into
whatever situation just you know so I
can be a father I'm waiting for the
right moment and I feel like
he's made all the mistakes that he could
have possibly made
and and he was a role model for me in
terms of what not to do right
so when it's time for you to become a
father you know what not to do
yes right if somehow by accident let's
say unlikely but by accident I have a
kid I just I guess I have to just drop
everything it's not about my life
anymore you know I can do it from
personal experience because I share the
same sentiments as you because I was
raised without my father and um he was
he disappointed me and he had like five
children that he disappointed so it
wasn't just me
um but what it done to me is that it
made me understand what I don't want to
be like but a lot of the times when it
comes to fatherhood and children who
don't have fathers is that they turn out
just like their fathers they do the same
things you know they repeat the same
cycles that their father did so I just
commend you on that so you know Well
Done keep going just just to say this is
this is an example like just because my
father was like that doesn't mean that
Society should look down on Fathers as a
whole you know because then you instill
that sentiment and then men think like
oh well everyone else is doing it you
know
why are you looking at me for and and
that gives them the opportunity to for
them to be irresponsible
we should encourage people we should
like uh we should encourage like fathers
like we should we should see fatherhood
the same way as we see motherhood
because then we avoid all these problems
you know because I'll read something uh
because in 2020
2020 there were
15.3 million children in the United
States with
a single mother without a father in
their life and the amount of single
fathers there were is 3.2 million
so single motherhood like when I asked a
question before like do mothers you know
get seen as the better parent if a child
did you say something yeah if a child
does get into a situation where he has
to go with one the parents it's normally
the mother that they go with well women
are incentivized to do that because they
get more child support if they get if
the father gets less custody
and so like we'll complain all day about
men not being in you know the kids lives
or whatever
um and not not the years was a different
situation but like we're literally
paying women to not to get the father
out of the home
even even I had um Auntie on here Auntie
Jenny yeah aren't you saying how like
back in her day if they were the girls
wanted to move out of the house they'd
just get pregnant because the government
would give them a apartment yep is that
a good way to bring a child into the
world
yeah and it honestly just speaks to like
women nowadays you know um my mom told
me my dad did not give any sort of money
no no Alamo no nothing you know and um I
was thinking about it like if
something happens if if I inherit
something you know because at the end of
the day he was my father
what should I do and and I came to the
conclusion out of Integrity I have to
refuse it I have to refuse anything that
that man gives me because that then it
means that like I'm just
I'm just unable unable to to make my own
future without you know without him like
out of principle you've you haven't been
there I don't need your you know
what are you doing I don't know you know
I would take it yeah
I mean a few casinos in there I mean I
understand he wouldn't he wouldn't
nothing that he could give me would be
enough for me to justify giving away my
Integrity
he's not successful so how would it how
how has it sorry affected you
not having your father around it's been
hard because uh I didn't as a child I
didn't know how to be masculine
um I would get beaten up bullied a lot
at school I I would be afraid to fight
back I had the glass made of glass
syndrome you know I was afraid that if I
if I punch something someone like they
would just shatter because
I don't know like I just was not taught
to defend myself my mom you know
she couldn't really
educate me and on that side of stuff so
it definitely had an impact on me I had
to I had to learn everything I had to
learn from the streets I had to
go through the hard bits you know get
robbed get beaten up
um and and it and it was a grueling
grueling situation but uh I think I came
out of it
quite well and quite um it could have
been worse I could have come out real
I think your story is you know one of
the reasons why we say fathers are so
important you know um I think Society
pushes fathers out of their home if you
go to the um
fathers for Justice website it shows
that 200 children per day are removed
from their
father by the family court system
um so I think the society doesn't really
value fatherhood for so many fathers to
be removed and I think it's very easy
for they pay you yeah they pay you to do
it
so you're literally paid out to be a
single mother so I have I have two
points to make the first one is
um all children born uncivilized someone
has to civilize these children so if
you're two people who are drug addicts
then you can conceive a child is it
irresponsible of you to conceive a child
and the circumstances you are or is it
unfair on the child okay
so I'm gonna just do one at a time so
you said if you're both drug addicts
yeah it's irresponsible to have a child
I would agree yeah okay so we all know
where that's going to go with the child
when they're conceived right yeah we all
know anomaly happens I don't want to be
an anomaly okay and where I work I get
to see a lot of birth certificates
and my life is social experiments in
general so I'll pick up on little things
a lot of single mothers don't have their
father's names on the birth certificate
of their child I'm I'm sorry if I'm a
father I want to see my name on that we
do I'm sorry what are you doing where's
my name in that that is my child like
how disrespectful would that be what do
you think of this man that's just
inseminated you and then you conceive
the child and then you don't even put
his name on it yeah are you like serious
because men are not respected yeah and
then what was that I I also think it's
like they say it's a form of hypergamy
because a girl doesn't want to be
associated with that Man's last name
because that's not the best she could do
you're happy to have sex and get your
vagina filled I didn't say it's a good I
didn't say I recommended it I'm just
like highlighting this to people like
someone are raising these people like
this yeah somebody's raising this
consistent cycle because if you grow up
in a household with Mom and Dad are
married they are presenting you of the
examples of relation issue between two
people who raising children and if you
have a good good relationship with your
mom and your dad or whatever you think
it is you tend to adopt those
relationships and take into your life as
an adult most women who have a great
relationship with their fathers they
tend to bond with men most of the time
and most men who have a good
relationship with their mothers they
tend to have a good relationship with
females along the way especially if the
environment they're in isn't violent
abusive drug-related it's it's you don't
need to be millionaire you don't need to
be extremely educated basic level of
parenting provides that
as many of you know I was just bad on
Tick Tock and
Ties on a daily
berm if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible